today uh you know the the philosopher uh
jonathan wolfe makes a point that you
know and and kind of philosophical
circles utilitarianism has kind of lost
a certain amount of legitimate geode
and yet at that same time
that it lost the kind of philosophical
legitimacy at a kind of bureaucratic
level at the state level it became the
kind of dominant model for policy making
so everything is you know subjected to
kind of cost benefit analysis
[Music]
hello plastic pills listeners we are
here with a very special guest today
neil
baleli who teaches at the university of
otago and is completing actually a
postdoc in history department right now
and he is the author of a very
interesting uh and extremely readable
new book futilitarianism
neoliberalism and the production of
uselessness uh some of you might
remember i reviewed it for jacobin
magazine you can check that out there
but the book just recently came out and
has included
some high praise from luminaries like
wendy brown and jessica white
who many of you know were very fond of
at the channel so thanks a lot for
coming on neil we really looking forward
to talking to you today
thanks so much matt thanks for having me
on
absolutely so just before we dive into
the kind of meat and potatoes of
utilitarianism
and what inspired you to write this uh
can you tell us a little bit about who
you are what interested you in this
topic uh and what your academic uh or
personal background is
yeah thanks thanks matt so um you can
probably tell from my accent that um i
am irish so i did my ba ma degrees at
queen's university in belfast
then i moved over to new zealand
to do my phd
and my phd was in literary studies kind
of nowhere near any of this kind of
content um and when i came out my phd as
you will know matt and many of your
listeners and even your colleagues will
know um finding a kind of academic job
market where there are absolutely no
jobs um
so the genesis for this book kind of
began in 2016 when adult tiger were
where i teach
uh the university went through a wave of
cuts to the humanities division
and there were lots of protests against
the cats and so on and so forth
but it's got i i originally started
thinking about this idea of futility
around around the humanities and
thinking about
how the humanities come to be
seen as useless
um and not to think simply about
you know protecting that uselessness you
know there's lots of thinkers who would
argue
we need to do these things just because
they are important or so on and so forth
to defend that kind of uselessness but
it's more to think about how do things
come to be
constructed as useless
and so that's kind of the the genesis of
this project um
and then it developed
more
the more i kind of looked into it the
more i started realizing this idea of
futility
was kind of rife across society it
wasn't it wasn't simply to do humanities
it was even simply due to university
um it's a kind of
experience that many people encounter in
different avenues of life
and so the project really just took kind
of uh
developed from there and i really
cracked i think
made a good crack in it in 2018
uh but it was kind it was it was strange
because
you know as i said my phd is in literary
studies i was going into a completely
new area um an area that i've obviously
been very interested in
um
and i was kind of
dabbling as well from kind of in
phenomenology and i've been really
interested listening to your recent
podcasts on
uh myrtle ponty um because he's the kind
of
uh grinding of my own kind of
philosophical practice um
yeah so i was
i felt like i was kind of stabbing in
the dark for a while but eventually it
kind of came to fruition and and
it's
the final piece is obviously the book
utilitarianism well i have to say you
can definitely tell that you come from a
background in literary studies
um because
it's a well-written book uh i mean
as you know typically when you're
assigned something on neoliberalism and
it has the dreaded theory pejorative you
kind of think intellectually this is
going to be very interesting
but it's going to be a slog to get
through uh you know there's going to be
a lot of head scratching moments
but i mean i cut through this in
probably about two days um
just because it was actually really
affecting uh and that's one of the
things that really comes through in your
writing also which is that
maybe in a very pontian sense uh you're
not kind of impartial or abstracted away
from this material it really feels lived
in in a certain sense
and that passion comes through in the
text so could you maybe talk a little
bit about
what inspired you uh emotionally uh or
theoretically write the book before we
start diving into uh the real nuts and
bolts of it
yeah cool that's i mean that's very kind
matt and it's something i really want to
um
i feel like i should say that it
reminded me a bit of uh and this is how
i praise because i'm a fan yeah mark
fisher's writing uh yeah you know not
not exactly doing
this clinical kind of analysis uh that
you might expect from somebody but
really living uh the material that
you're writing about yeah that i mean
that's that's the highest praise really
um
yeah i think fisher is such an
extraordinary
writer and um and i think it's the kind
of energy that he brings to his work and
i guess
i think for me probably my background in
literary studies
is really helpful when it comes to
writing these about this kind of topic
because it does give you a grinding and
how to
kind of tell a story and how to hold a
reader on some level
and i was really
really conscious the whole time writing
and i think in all my writing um whether
it's my academic
research or or any other writing i've
done for
kind of more general audience i am
really cognizant on on the writing being
kind of
readable and and enjoyable and effective
and i what really wanted with the book
because you're right you know
lots of the kind of discussions of
neoliberalism can be quite kind of
abstract and and operating at the kind
of high theoretical level and i really
wanted to combine like kind of high
theory and low theory in this text and
and and not to to
to simply
one thing i really didn't want to do was
just add another kind of denunciation of
neoliberalism to the kind of mountain
that is out there so i did want to build
a kind of theoretical project but at the
same time i wanted to grind that project
in kind of lived experience in in a kind
of
uh in affect i guess and
perhaps even as you can touch on there
that that stands for my kind of grinding
in in someone like myrtle ponty's work
but so so it um those
those are two things i really kept in
mind was one i want this to be
kind of read almost in a kind of
novelistic way um but also to to combine
that kind of high theory and low theory
um
in the book and it's really i mean i was
really pleased with your review and that
you kind of picked up on that and others
have as well that they've they find it a
really readable book um which is
kind of great it's kind of
exactly the kind of praise i i was
hoping for
oh absolutely uh well
i'd say actually the
densest part of the book or at least the
one that's the most technical uh are the
initial few chapters and that's actually
one of the things that i want us to
start talking about
because
the book is about neoliberalism and the
kind of utilitarian condition that it
brings about uh but you locate the root
uh theoretical and ideological of the
kind of neoliberal era uh in
a somewhat unexpected place the kind of
philosophical doctrine of utilitarianism
as espoused by people like jeremy
bentham uh john stuart mill
and henry citric
and i'm just wondering if you could talk
a little bit about
why utilitarianism uh is such a focus
for you and how it is that at least
an element of utilitarianism uh because
it's quite a complicated analysis leads
to something like the neoliberal ethos
yeah and i think that's um
i think it is a kind of surprising place
in
in some way it was surprising for me
when i even um came to to kind of take
this this avenue into neoliberalism
but i think
it's utilitarianism is a really
important
doctrine anything about neoliberalism
precisely because
i guess i i'll start at i kind of where
we are now and kind of almost work
backwards but
that that
today uh you know the the philosopher uh
jonathan wolfe makes a point that you
know and kind of philosophical circles
utilitarianism has kind of lost a
certain amount of legitimacy
and yet at that same time
that it lost the kind of philosophical
legitimacy at a kind of bureaucratic
level at the state level it became the
kind of dominant model for policy making
so everything is you know subjected to
kind of cost benefit analysis
um you weigh up kind of
uh the pleasures against the the pains
and so on and so forth so it's so in
many ways utilitarian utilitarian
thinking has become central to kind of
governance in our period
but i was more interested here on kind
of
i i guess
i think you were picked up in the book i
was kind of more interested in the kind
of
subjectification that kind of occurs
under under neoliberalism
and so i was thinking more about
the way that neoliberalism demands
the kind of ear we live in now it
demands this kind of hyper utility
maximization that we must continually
maximize our utility make ourselves kind
of
the most useful we can be to maximize
our human capital so on and so
forth and yet at the same time
neoliberalism
seems to completely undercut
the the kind of structures the social
relations that can actually
turn
that kind of practice of utility
maximization into some kind of
collective happiness which is the you
know the greatest happiness principle
which is the finding
kind of idea at the center of
utilitarianism which is you know
the the most moral course of action is
the one that maximizes the greatest
amount of happiness for the greatest
amount of people and
that's kind of completely severed under
neoliberalism so essentially utility
maximization
what i argue and this is what the the
utilitarianism is is that we all
maximize utility now but in doing so we
actually worsen
our kind of collective social and
economic conditions so it's almost it's
a kind of an inversion of the
utilitarian the thought this is not and
saying that i'm not arguing that their
utilitarianism is therefore a great
theory and we should move back to some
sort of utilitarian utopia i think
there's inherent issues with
utilitarianism from the very get-go but
that's the kind of where i get to with
the piece
i guess why i went back to
the kind of intellectual history of
utilitarianism is
you know the intellectual history is one
of the
uh
is one of the key approaches to
neoliberalism um
uh through you know people philip
moroski or theater playway or
even jessica white quinceanian's work
um looking at the kind of key thinkers
of the new liberal
um period so i i think i took a slight
diversion into a different kind of
intellectual history to show that
actually the neoliberals were
sometimes consciously and sometimes
perhaps unconsciously
working
with and against a kind of utilitarian
idea
are you a utilitarian thought sorry um
someone like hayek for instance
explicitly
um
uh talks about bentham's work and
extremely kind of critical bentham's
work and as i show in the first chapter
at the same time keynes is is also a
kind of anti-benthamite utilitarianism
and yet they're coming at it from
completely different directions
so um
i'm not sure i've fully answered your
question there but i think
oh no no definitely i mean
this is kind of the interesting jumping
off point um for your analysis of
utilitarianism for me because
as i pointed out in the review and as
you point out over the course
of the book utilitarianism has meant a
lot of different things to a lot of
different people right uh there are
radical kinds of utilitarianism uh that
might be actually quite amenable to a
kind of egalitarian politics and
somebody that i talk a little bit about
um in my own work is something like js
mel
who identified at the end of his life as
a socialist advocate for workers
democracy so on uh and even bet them you
know at democratic inclinations near the
end of his life but that doesn't
necessarily have to be the case and
what's kind of interesting as a
historical point in your text
is the jumping off point where
utilitarianism kind of split into two
different branches uh one was a kind of
anti-benthamite keynesianism which
focused on kind of a moderate welfare
state managing the crises of capital all
the stuff you discuss
and then the other is neoliberalism and
both of them took elements of classical
utilitarianism uh but went really far
afield with them yeah so could you maybe
let's put the keynesian one aside we'll
talk about that some other day uh
how did neoliberalism pick up on these
kinds of utilitarian things but then as
you very artfully put it in the book
kind of invert one's expectations uh so
rather than producing the greatest
possible happiness for the greatest
number of people it produces
extraordinary unhappiness uh for many
people uh and yet still obtains a kind
of ideological
not just hegemony but a hegemonic
connection to at least elements of this
kind of cost-benefit analysis we
associate with utilitarianism yes yeah
that's that's very well put and i think
um so
yeah setting aside the kind of keynesian
one because i think that's probably
quite self-evident um
yeah i think that that was the kind of
where i wanted that's what i wanted to
show is that that neoliberalism does
dolls in some way
evolve
a utilitarian view of the world
um and what ends up happening is that it
as i really kind of intimated towards
and it manages to find a way to
centralize
um
or to place utility maximization at the
kind of heart of the way that we behave
in the world without having to provide
at all
this kind of collective or or um
aggregate of kind of social welfare
um so what this goes back for instance
particularly in high ex work who he
really does directly engage with bentham
in a
very critical way
but what i end up pinpointing in the
book is that
even though hayek is extremely critical
of bentham he ends up instituting a very
similar view of society to bentham which
is society as a collection of individual
interests or particularly self-interest
um and he you know
um and that's what bentham bentham says
you know it's vain to talk about the
idea of community that community is
simply just the
the um
aggregation of all these kind of
individual interests individual desires
um and this is exactly you know um
high basic makes the exact same point
you know that that social ends are the
ends of kind of uh of all individual
kind of desires so so the social is
never a kind of totality at all for for
either of them it's only ever a kind of
a kind of aggregation of individual
interests
and this has become is central to kind
of particularly benthamite
utilitarianism and i think
you very helpfully point out in your
review is that that's not necessarily
the same as
some other versions of utilitarianism
particularly mills utilitarianism
particularly towards the end of his life
um i mean there is a as i think you
pointed out as well another
there is a kind of
elitism to mill's work that is
particularly problematic yeah and and
um but i think the point still stands
that there is a more
at least a project within utilitarianism
that is more amenable to a kind of
democratic socialist politics that
particularly bent them there there's a
real um
[Music]
uh authoritarian streak in bentham's
work uh oh definitely i mean yeah i
remember uh
he wrote a piece about why it is
everyone should get tattooed uh so
it'll be easier for us to identify
any better society right um
yeah so when foco you know kind of talks
about uh you know panopticism as a kind
of proto-authoritarian outlook uh this
wasn't just him uh stretching uh a
metaphor right bentham really did have
these really warped kind of inclinations
uh at points yeah exactly he was he was
a very lit kind of literal thinker like
he wasn't really working at an abstract
level
yeah what he said is what he meant
i mean you gotta give him props for that
it's true i mean yeah he's one of those
kind of people that every now and then
emerges in the history of political
thought where he comes up with this
interesting kind of argument where you
might think okay cost benefit analysis
but then he just runs to the extreme
with it
he's like if we have to barrel through
every kind of common sense intuition uh
every kind of plausible more argument
against this uh in order to kind of push
this conclusion to the utmost then so be
it that's what we'll do
and
you kind of almost got to give him a few
props for that because it leads him to
really weird places yeah
that's that's [ __ ] up but at least
he's willing to go there you know yeah
exactly yeah it's helpful in that regard
um
and i think that's why
thinkers from the kind of neoliberal
kind of thought collective or
um do pick up on aspects of
utilitarianism but but reject the kind
of overall
project of utilitarianism
um and what i think they find unit
utilitarianism is a main is an ability
to identify
that utility maximum
utility maximization can be used
in in airing in in
in protecting capitalism from democracy
whereas i think you know when someone
like mills work in particular
he he sees that idea of utility
maximization as a way of enhancing
democracy or protecting
um
protecting the demos from
excesses of capitalism
but i think for the neoliberals it's the
other way around that they actually see
that the pro the the
process of utility maximization as a way
of
instilling a kind of hyper productivity
at the heart of capitalism but also as
as a way not to provide that kind of
uh
social
relation social structure that can
guarantee the greatest happiness
principle that can give some sort of
greatest happiness degree this number
and so it's basically utility
maximization towards
individual survival
um
and that's that's kind of where i get to
with that that we then enter this kind
of utilitarian period where we're all
trying to maximize your utility but in
doing so
we end up
the kind of our our um collective
conditions get worse and worse and
many of us find ourselves trapped in
that cycle whether it's in the
university whether it's in general
society and anywhere
it's kind of pervasive rationality i
think oh absolutely and i mean that's
the kind of dark dialectic uh that your
book takes us down uh so i should say
again uh
not an uplifting book uh utilitarianism
uh but in the best sense of the word
that is kind of a call to action in some
senses uh to not think of uh agitation
as utah but you know i think the point
that you're bringing up there uh really
for me was at the heart of the book so
uh as you kind of point out in the text
there's this theoretical tension at the
heart of utilitarian doctrine between
what's sometimes called
rational hedonism
and universal hedonism right or this
belief that
utilitarians hold that we're all
self-interested creatures that we all
try to maximize our individual utility
at all costs but at the same time some
utilitarian thinkers at least argued
that
we should almost paradoxically set that
aside and focus on securing the greatest
happiness for the greatest number of
people
and there's this found a fundamental
tension within the doctrine uh that you
highlight uh that henry citric actually
brought to the fore in his work probably
most clearly uh and you say that kind of
what neoliberals do is they chuck all
this stuff about a moral obligation to
secure the greatest happiness to the
greatest number of people which at least
would be somewhat outward directed
and they say no benjamin was right
people are just self-interested in
animals all that we do uh is pursue our
subjective pleasures
at all costs and indifferent to the kind
of concerns of everyone else and they
create an economic system
that
matches that and one of the kind of
consequences of this and this speaks to
the common point you make up about
freedom
as they reconceive a freedom purely
along the lines of the pursuit
of utility maximization by individual
actors so you're free if you have a
choice between
50 different flavors of ice cream
because now you have 50 different
flavors you can choose from and you can
choose any one that you want as long as
you pay for them that's what freedom is
but freedom does not include a right to
for instance democratically choose
not to exist in an economic system where
that's the range of choices that are
provided for you and no more uh so
considerations of things like democratic
or social freedom those are put to the
side uh even questions about substantive
freedom
like the kind of freedom that i might
have if uh
i was poor and i had more material
resources to kind of pursue my life
goals even that's uh put aside uh and
that to me at least is the real problem
uh with neoliberal doctrine uh and why
it feels like such an unfree society
because so many of these important
choices are taken away from us and
replaced with the argument that well at
least now you have 50 flavors of ice
cream yeah
would you say that that's a kind of
accurate depiction of the political
conclusion of your book and can you
maybe elaborate on some of these ideas
because it really reminded me a bit of
people like quinn slovadian wendy brown
or jessica white others who have kind of
talked in this direction yeah definitely
and it's not i mean it's not surprising
i think you've really identified that
that their work is quite influential in
my own thinking about neoliberalism but
i think that's a really brilliant um
synopsis of exactly
the idea that i'm trying to promote to
put forward in the book it is exactly
that's the version of freedom that we
get and you know in her work jessica
white calls it a kind of margin of
freedom that neoliberalism produces is
is that
um
it
it
kind of takes place in the name of
freedom
and it gives us this kind of illusion of
freedom but it's a very limited version
of freedom so you're right you get
you get to choose between 50 different
ice creams but you have no choice on on
how you pay for ice cream how ice cream
is produced hi so on and so forth it's
it's very kind of
self-interested and
um
anti-relational
and again i'm thinking back to kind of
little ponte there
and it's it's no coincidence that you
know bentham's fault in particular
was was kind of celebrated by many of
the kind of classical and then kind of
neoclassical economists um
i met i think the
editor of bentham's collected works for
nurse stark he he called bentham and
david ricardo the kind of flesh of one
flesh that they shared this kind of
essential this belief that man is
essentially a selfish animal
and and not just that it is selfish
animal but it's it's useless to fight
that selfishness that we should actually
just embrace it um
and and there's of course there's
crossovers there with the kind of
neoliberal thinkers and the way that
they conceive
of freedom
and wendy braun also makes a similar
point you know that you you know
neoliberal takes place in in the name of
freedom and yet it tears up freedom's
grounding at every um
at every juncture
um
and that that's the kind of
point i i get i make in the book at one
point is that this it's freedom to be
completely
alone on some level it's freedom
to be
uh cast aside and
basically
to sink or swim that's the kind of
version of freedom that emerges under
under neoliberalism um
[Music]
and and i draw on the book on vince
hansworth kind of german media theorist
and
um and he he you know talked about um
that capital gives us
um capital promotes a certain version of
freedom that suits capital
and we
interpret that freedom as if it's our
freedom so we we end up kind of
taking on a capitalist version of
freedom that that actually cements the
kind of
hegemonic um situation of capitalism and
yet we
we interpret that as our freedom that's
our our desire our it's our role to kind
of fulfill the freedom that capital
needs us to do and and that's where i
think civilians work is really important
and and i think
i i saw him i think it was a tweet
actually someone asked him to describe
neoliberalism in one
one sentence and he said
the continual protection of capitalism
from democracy and i think that's a kind
of real succinct
definition of exactly how
neoliberalism works and and
the impact that has therefore on the
idea of freedom which i think you've
articulated really well there
um
and i think i'd be interested because
from reading your work as well like when
you come to talk
because you're obviously very well
personal kind of liberal tradition when
you come to think of neoliberalism how
do you
define it in your own work
oh i tend to define it in exactly the
way that uh slovadin did uh
effort to encase the market uh from
democratic and political pressures uh
and to insist that
the kinds of freedoms that are offered
by a capitalist uh relations production
are the only kind of freedoms that are
worth having or somebody even go farther
and say that they're the only kind of
freedoms that we can't have right yeah
uh i mean i think
hayek was sometimes more sensitive to
this uh than somebody like lou dignita
would be
in the sense that he would say there are
other kinds of freedom that people might
want like democratic freedoms but they
are so dangerous uh and they are so
useless that we should not prioritize
them and in fact he consistently would
say things like uh if we have a choice
between a democratic socialist society
uh and an authoritarian liberal society
no question we should have an
authoritarian neoliberal society i would
add right uh because that would be
in his understanding more free and at
the very least more prosperous uh than a
democratic society uh and i should also
add that i'm not here to dis ice cream
right i do think that having 50
different flavors of ice cream and be
able to choose between them is a kind of
freedom uh and i don't have a problem
with it when i'm at the supermarket
right uh but if you were to ask me what
kind of freedoms do i think are more
meaningful uh the choice between 50
different brands of ice cream
or the choice to be able to decide what
kind of economic system i want to live
under or what the power relations in my
society are going to be uh then no
question uh i would choose that to say
that those are more important i don't
actually think we have to choose because
i hope that on a democratic socialist
society we still have 50 flavors plus
kinds of ice cream yeah at least 49
maybe
at least 49. yeah yeah but the kind of
suggestion that that's not integral uh
to human freedom just strikes me as
not just like normally wrong but also a
bad description of who we are to kind of
get back to the utilitarian uh kind of
presupposition um but you're just kind
of moving on because this is what i
thought was the most
darkly kind of funny part of your book
uh when you talk about how it is that
not just we exist in this kind of
society
we live in a society as it knows memes
sometimes say right but how people
internalize these expectations and
reflect them uh and how the kind of
ideological culture of the time uh
really becomes almost this kind of comic
pastiche of neoliberal logics
so in the book you talk a little bit
about how it is that
neoliberalism uh
sometimes consciously uh sometimes
unconsciously try to re-mold us into
thinking of human subjectivity along
entrepreneurial lines where you need to
see yourself not just your labor but now
your actual self as a kind of capital
that continuously need to be valorized
marketed improved
and this really darkly funny part uh you
talk about um
tom peters article uh for fast company
the brand called you uh
where he says look you need to start
seeing yourself as a brand that you're
going to continuously
try to improve upon
and then he lists all these different
techniques to do so
and you point out that this is
really a horrifying kind of image of
human subjectivity
one that's extraordinarily alienating
and dehumanizing just to use the
old-fashioned terms and i was wondering
if you could talk a little bit about it
because
for somebody like me it is precisely the
way that neoliberalism reshapes our
subjectivity that really speaks to
its perverse quality uh and what's
really disturbing about its logics
yeah thanks matt and
that's that's really cool and and
it's been nice actually people when i
have talked about people even though as
you said it is kind of a kind of dark
book
um i did want to have moments of kind of
comedy in there to kind of alleviate
um the darkness um but yeah so i think
as i said that
i am really interested here in the kind
of subjective phase subjectification
associated with with neoliberalism so
how we come to think of ourselves as
subjects uh how we interpret our
behaviors
um sometimes how we don't even think
about our behaviors and which i guess is
more in the kind of focolean approach to
neoliberalism although i wouldn't
necessarily describe myself as a as a
[ __ ]
um and i think
this idea of the brand called you really
epitomizes the the impact of of how we
actually constructed the subject
something the funny thing about this
article and this comes through in your
book is this isn't intended as some kind
of sinister manifesto right it's not
like a ci report saying we need to
remake people to this it's done in this
kind of extraordinarily chipper fashion
right you know think about the ways that
you can improve uh marketing yourself
think about what you could do to
transform yourself into a more likable
kind of personality right all these
kinds of
banalities uh
that are kind of troped out as just
common sense wisdom uh that's what's
really kind of
darkly funny uh about this article
yeah i think that's that's the the the
scary part of that article is it's done
in good faith and um
and with any without no hint of irony is
basically we should behave as if we are
a billboard at all
points of our life that we should never
stop thinking about it he says that you
know our our prior our our priority is
to be head marketer of me inc you know
that's yeah that's how we now behave as
individuals and for me it's such a
terrifying kind of vision of humanity
and yet it seems so
caught i think that's the article it
just seems so logical in the way that he
describes it's like why wouldn't we
behave like this
um
and this i you know i pinpoint this
within the kind of logic of human
capital which
really became central to to
neoliberal economic theory particularly
under gary becker's work and the idea
that we
we are um we build
kind of um everything that we do as
individuals as a kind of contribute
contribution towards our human capital
and it's often the same this was the
logic that kind of underpins the
transformation of
of say higher education from a social
right to a kind of thing that you pick
to service the thing that you pay for
is that why should the state pay for
um
your education when you're the one that
will benefit from it it's your human
capital that you are investing in and if
you invest in it and make the wrong
decision and you can't get a job well
it's actually you've made a bad
investment it's nothing to do with the
state and this is kind of grounding of
human capital theory
and and and you see that in foucault's
work with the idea of the entrepreneurs
of the self is that the self becomes a
kind of thing
to sell essentially it becomes a
permanent kind of commercial project
that you're constantly having to invest
in and show to other people and sell
other people in a certain way and hope
that other people invest in it and you
build your human capital that way and
peter's article seems to just it just
takes that as a given as well this is
how humans always behave and therefore
you should make the most of it
and so therefore we get
what happens in a world where we all
behave as brands
is that there is no kind of capacity
for a kind of
uh for a relationality that isn't
competitive um again bing johann talks
about under this logic
it's impossible to have a relationship
that's that's free of purpose so
essentially every single interaction you
have with another
can is essentially a capitalist
relationship and you're competing
against one another for in the kind of
marketplace
of human relations
and a quote i think another quote that i
use on the book is from jeff bezos um
yeah
and talking about the idea of a personal
brand and again he says this with with
complete no irony with the sense that
this is a real positive thing but he
says your brand is what people say about
you when you're not in the room
and for me
such a statement is
is it couldn't be a more succinct
definition of paranoia but
the very thing one thing that enables us
to just be as human beings is that
we if we constantly have to think about
what others are saying about us behind
our backs we would be cripples we
wouldn't be able to move and to realize
how much your economic uh
and even physical destiny is bound up
with that
yeah so you now rise and fall on the
success of your brand and if your brand
is what people say when you're not in
the room uh you can't even be sure how
successful you are about that so you
need kind of this paranoia concern for
everything that's going on while you're
not present and when you're not invested
in your activities yeah exactly so you
can only yeah that's such a that is
exactly the point and and and it also
means that when you are in the room
can you really trust what people are
telling to your face if if all that
matters is what people say about you
when you're not there then you
completely have no control
over um how you are perceived by others
and i should say that i think people
really respond to this at an emotional
level i mean
take an episode of black mirror uh you
know uh what are the kind of recurring
tropes uh that's presented there uh
that's kind of critique of late
capitalism on occasion uh is this idea
that it's very hard for people to
actually be sincere with one another uh
not because people don't want to be
sincere or not because we've lost the
capacity for sincerity i think sometimes
that kind of critique is overstated but
precisely because we're so concerned
with marketing the brand called you uh
that we never are capable of actually
saying how it is that we feel about
something uh giving opinions that might
be controversial
upsetting everyone even if that might
have a positive benefit for them for the
broader society because that would be
damaging to the broad until you and it
creates not just this kind of paranoiac
uh society uh where we're constantly
wondering what other people are thinking
about us but also one where we feel that
we can't be
to use an old-fashioned term you know
true to ourselves yeah exactly and also
kind of confuses us within what is to be
true to yourself and in that sense is
and i see it with you know even um
teaching kind of students you know you
alert them to the idea of human capital
and they all say i don't want to i'm not
a piece of capital i don't want to think
about myself as capital
but then
at the same time they know that they
have to sort of kind of build a certain
version of themselves if they want to
you know be successful or
achieve you know particularly even in
especially in a kind of
avenues that used to be kind of
traditionally
and antithetical towards kind of
capitalism and like say the creative
arts or things is idea now to become a
writer or an artist or anything or even
academia right yeah academia yeah
exactly you have to build a kind of
brand that that people then built can
buy into and you build your human
capital that day and that's how you
become successful
um
and what this produces i think is is a
kind of community of of
that's characterized by both need and
distrust so
the need is that you need others to buy
into your brand so you're constantly
having to kind of sell yourself to
others but then this this deep distrust
that others have actually bought into
your brand
or a kind of wholeness that you think
do people actually
like do they even the sense do people
like me or do they like the version of
me that i'm selling
um or if you've built built a brand or
say you're a writer for instance and
you've built a brand and that's kind of
preceded your
um
avenue into becoming a well-known writer
is are people do people see you as a
good writer or do they simply have they
bought into your brand is this kind of
so you're you're always left with this
kind of hollowness i think in that
situation
and this stands for the fact that
we can never know what others really
think of us
um
so that
it's it's a really kind of crippling
condition and as you said it can only
lead to a kind of sense of paranoia
and this is the kind of illusory
community that that neoliberal
capitalism produces um that even you
know marx talked about the kind of
illusory community of capitalism where
there's of course a class domination
within within that system
and as marx argues it's actually only
the ruling class that gets experience a
proper version of freedom a kind of one
where you can be true to to yourself to
use that kind of term
um
but he makes the opposite argument
essentially that actually individuals
obtain their freedom through their
associations with other individuals on a
um
legitimate and genuine level not as a
version of brand and this is really odds
with neoliberal rationality where where
freedom is which you touched on earlier
freedom is always seen as freedom from
others
rather than freedom with others
um
and and so in a kind of world of self
brands there only ever is competition
like competition can only be the kind of
the logic that that develops
um and this to me is really kind of
crippling political position um and yet
it's really scary how even on the left
how this this kind of
uh
this rationality of of self branding has
become really kind of prominent um
so i guess that's what i try to i think
using peter's article is
was hopefully useful in in that regard
that it is so what's the word like um
obvious or so so
it's so written in good faith that it
actually is terrifying
that the kind of naivety of it oh
absolutely right uh it's the kind of
markusian uh one-dimensionality or
flatness to it uh that's really
disturbing this notion that uh the
article is all about surface uh and it's
become
our society has been so superficial that
nobody sees any problem with being
surface any longer right uh the depth
isn't really required for you to be able
to market yourself successfully but i i
think there is a kind of depth uh that
we see in neoliberal subjects but not
necessarily the kind you want which is
kind of what i was going to move on to
next because you talk a lot in the book
about this sense of
what alternative is responsibilization
that neoliberalism poses upon us this
sense that
according to market logic uh you rise
and fall on your own merits we all know
that that's untrue uh but this is the
kind of ideology that's promulgated uh
and
once upon a time uh this is bad enough
when you think about the exploitation
that was undertaken under classical
capitalism right where you went in for
your job you worked really hard uh
the product of your labor was
appropriated from you kind of classical
market story but what's problematic
about neoliberalism in your take
is how since we're now all our own kind
of brand
when you fail it's not just that you
didn't work hard enough is that there's
something fundamentally wrong about
everything that society sees as being
important about you right
the brand that is you
was a bust people don't like you and
this leads to a tremendous sense of
responsibilization that goes way deeper
than when people experienced before when
they were in conditions of economic
precarity
and what's interesting about this i
think also is the sense of powerlessness
that instills because while we all
associate the neoliberal era with being
able to do what it is that you want uh
with kind of
yolo type mentalities
because it does lead people to feel so
responsible for the individual life and
so connect disconnected from everyone
else to the center where they can't form
uh kind of communities for collective
action because everyone's competing with
one another uh there's
very little power to actually change
anything
so all we can do is kind of feel
impotent in the face of large-scale
social problems uh that we know we need
to do something about but since none of
us can do anything about it individually
and we're all made to feel responsible
for not being able to do that
nothing gets done and the situation
worsens and this is kind of the
pessimistic takeaway i got from the book
would you say that that's accurate uh
and i suppose just to kind of
move to a more uplifting uh kind of
narrative is there anything we can do
about that yeah i think that that is the
kind of
that that's the condition which i call
the utilitarian condition that i'm
trying to articulate um
i will talk a bit about how we might
move beyond that but yeah exactly that's
the
is that we get trapped in this kind of
cycle of of
i guess failure i think the point you
made there about that that the failure
goes deeper than than
perhaps where it used to in a kind of
classic kind of capitalist exploitation
and it's almost i think that's i haven't
quite articulated in that way but it's
almost like a kind of it's not like an
ontological failure it's not just the
kind of i would say so yeah i mean yeah
it's not enough now just to sit there
and be like uh
you're not you're gonna get a shitty
wage and you're not gonna be able to
look after your family uh it's that
you're getting a shitty wage you're not
gonna be able to look after your family
and that's not just because you didn't
work hard enough it's because there's
something wrong with you yeah exactly
yeah so
yeah such a and that's a really
important development i think and like a
really terrifying development
yeah it goes beyond that
it's actually something it's not
something wrong with the system it's not
something even wrong with
with the job the specific job we do is
something specifically wrong with your
being
and it's no surprise that in that kind
of
in a world where that kind of
that level of domination and failure
lands at the kind of
ontological level that we see the rise
that we do live in a kind of period of
kind of
you know mental health kind of epidemic
and
again seeing it with um
with students and or kind of our
generation and the younger generation
of kind of coming into the world that
the
kind of neoliberal world has been well
established
it that actually
anxiety and depression are quite logical
responses to through the kind of
conditions that we that we encounter um
and this is where
i i find uh julie dean's work quite
helpful in in that regard and
that she
you know
we talk a lot about the kind of
pathologies of of capitalism at early
late capitalism which are
you know depression anxiety
um
other forms of kind of mental health
issues um and mark fisher has written
about this you know as mental health as
a political issue rather than a kind of
individual or or even health issue um
but johnny dean makes us makes this
really nice artic
articulation that i find really helpful
is that she she argues that it's that
they these the pathology isn't anxiety
or depression or anything like that the
pathology is the individual form itself
it's a pathological position
to take
that that we are simply completely
responsible for our own individual
well-being
and this kind of pervasive individualism
that's that's
what
breeds kind of depression anxiety and i
think you've articulated it in a way
that actually is very helpful
in that it's it's a ontological
um failure that we experience and
therefore
this really limit and this is part of
the kind of domination the kind of
aggressive nature of neoliberalism is
that it it puts us into a position that
i call this utilitarian condition where
we are incapable of
um changing the kind of circumstances in
which we live because we have been so
kind of atomized and we're so kind of
crushed that we we aren't able to kind
of put together
um
it's not we aren't but but in general
the kind of collective action needed is
kind of not there
um
and and and
interesting i think as well certain
development dealers in post 2008 you
know other scholars have talked about
you know punitive neoliberalism
pierre dardell christian and the val
talk about
post 2008 new neoliberalism is a war
against the population
so i think in earlier stages
neoliberalism was more kind of passive
domination you know incentivizing
certain ways of behaving
like incentivizing entrepreneurialism so
on and so forth and then posterizing me
it was a kind of more
dominating of active domination all
posterity and things and things like
that so i think um getting back to to
the kind of point that that you were
making when we get trapped in the kind
of utilitarian condition
it really limits our capacity
to
to to do anything about
the situation which we find ourselves in
and so where i move towards at the end
of the book is
towards the idea of what i call the
futilitarian which is also a kind of
play on the idea of the prokaryote
but in the same way that that precarity
has
been a really helpful
term for
naming a kind of shared experience that
many people ex
people share across
um society and that has been used for
action um
i kind of collect uh political groups
that have been
organized around the idea of precarity
particularly precarious work
i see a similar potential in the idea of
futility and what i argue is actually
the concept of futility
extends beyond
precarity that that many of us recognize
riccardi many of us might be in
precarious situations i guess we're all
i guess we are all in precarious
situation given kind of climate change
but but many people would not describe
themselves as precarious
but
i think lots of people will recognize
this concept the the
idea of utility
even if they are you know in a in a
steady job or they have a good income
they have a house and so on so forth
this idea of utility dolls kind of
shadow us and
haunt us
on some level and so what i moved
towards is that
that actually this shared experience
futility not to say that that some
people's experience of utility is also a
lot more crippling than others
but it still can be the basis of a kind
of shared political project
and i'm not arguing towards any kind of
you know um innovative model of
political organization or anything i
still think you know
unionization's good i think protests are
good i think any kind of collective
mobilization is good but i i think
what i'm trying to do is is to produce a
kind of
uh
uh something that would that can pull us
together on a kind of subjective level
or or an intersubjective level to say
this is this is an experience that we
share in some cases or form and actually
what neoliberalism wants us to think is
that that futility represents a defect
of our individual characters
but in recognizing it in one another and
recognizing that we all shared a sense
of utility we can actually direct it
outwards towards that's the system that
produces the experience of utility
and that's basically the aim of the book
is delay the kind of theoretical
foundations for that
um kind of what i call a becoming common
for a kind of
producing a kind of that simply we can
on a very simple level we can go yeah i
recognize i experience futility
and i see that other people have that
experience of utility perhaps this is
something we can use
to actually get us out of of the
utilitarian condition to see that it's
not all up to us that we are incapable
simply as individuals of changing the
world and the way that neoliberalism
suggests that we that we can
no absolutely and i have to say uh for
all i have characterized this is a dark
book and it is a dark book uh it does
end on a call to action and i have to
say that by the conclusion of it i
wasn't so much suppressed as angry uh i
wanted to do something uh and
i don't know about you but i'm a little
bit more optimistic uh maybe than i was
a year or two ago uh not that there
aren't extraordinary matters of concern
uh whether you talk about climate change
the ongoing uh coveted epidemic uh or
the resurgence of the far right in a lot
of countries too many countries but at
the same time we've seen a kind of mild
social democratic surge in some european
countries if you think about the recent
election of the spd in germany uh
neoliberal sorry uh there was gabriel
borick and his victory in chile which i
think is itself historically quite
telling uh if you think of neoliberalism
as being birthed uh in a challenging
context
the fact that they've now kind of
overthrown the pinochet era i would hope
is a kind of symbol uh of things to come
so
why don't we end on that do you think
that there are any
reasons to be optimistic uh about an end
to the futilitarian neoliberal condition
uh and if so where do you see those
sources of optimism yeah i i agree and i
do try to say in the intro to the book
that this is ultimately an optimistic
endeavor but it i'm perhaps i'm more
trying to convince myself there and then
we always do right here yeah yeah
but i guess it was kind of too weird
to to go to the depths of the darkness
to actually then come up
or into like and i guess the conclusion
is an attempt to do that on some level
but i i really do see kind of
uh
hope and optimism
um
even in just not even just in recent
couple of recent developments but in the
last few years you can arise of a kind
of democratic socialist project um
um and the right i think chile is a
really important development i mean we
don't know how that's going to go yet
and you know greece gives us kind of
room to be slightly pessimistic but
given chile's kind of
um
symbolic importance with neoliberalism
and boric is you know
um kind of uh
catch for yourself you know this is the
kind of birthplace of neoliberalism
let's make it the kind of graveyard yeah
um and i do think it is a real really
important development in that regard
even just
and i think also
from a younger generation i think of
someone that care milburn's work on
generation left idea that there is a
kind of
growing
renewal of a kind of collectivist
left-wing project that is really hopeful
um
at the same time you know um others have
pointed out with with the book is that
this idea if you tell the the
futilitarian condition and then the kind
of subjective
impact of of that
can also lead towards more kind of
um
fascist kind of expressions of anger um
and that is the danger and guess what i
again what one of the what did walter
benjamin say though uh
jesus mentioned this at some point you
know uh fascism is always an expression
of a failed revolution you know i'm
paraphrasing uh but i always thought
that that was pretty telling
yeah and i think that's the danger is
that that this this kind of condition
that we're in that i'm trying to name
can quite as easy can quite easily
merge towards a kind of
more kind of active version of nihilism
that that overlaps with a kind of
fascist project
so one of the real aims of this book is
to try and
turn that sense of utility away from a
kind of um far right
nihilistic and and
um sort of nationalist project towards
a a kind of socialist a left-wing
communist kind of project in that um
but what in order to get to there we
have to actually kind of admit to
ourselves that this condition exists
that we have to recognize this utility
that and in part in the you know chapter
five of the book i go through some of
the kind of
problematic kind of what we might think
of as kind of left-wing or liberal
positions that actually just
cement the kind of neoliberal
rationality that see political the
political strictly through the eyes of
the individual
and and simply that this individual
action will will kind of change the
world and this is we have to move away
from that
but there is hope to show that that is
happening
um
i'm sure you i think as you said you see
yourself as more optimistic and and i i
am an optimistic person you probably
might not have
garnered that from from the book
um but i feel like
that
the aim of the book was to kind of
kind of delve into that darkness and
bring it to light and get us on the left
to kind of face it and to admit it on
some level
as a means to therefore put forward a
more optimistic version of the future
because if we let this kind of
utilitarian condition
fester and and and exist in the way that
it does and tick along without us really
confronting on some level it will
be captured by the right
and one thing you can say about the
rights
during the kind of liberal decades is
that they have managed
more
convincingly to capture the kind of
political imagination
um
but i think the left is beginning
to fight back on that and i think there
is a new imaginary kind of developing
and that's very exciting and what it
exactly looks like it's hard to know but
it it
it exists much more now than it did even
five six years ago and that yeah
is exciting um
so yeah i am optimistic i really i
really am
yeah no it's very exciting for me as
well uh and
uh
i'm hoping for a day uh where we don't
need to kind of
hold steadfastly uh to the kind of
gramsci injunction you know pessimism is
the intellect optimism of the will uh
because i do think there might be some
reasons for very cautious optimism of
the intellect giving recent transitions
but you know just a shameless capitalist
plug at the end as we need to do
utilitarianism neoliberalism and the
production of uselessness uh one of the
best books i read last year again short
sweet uh succinct uh you can get through
it in two days
100 percent pick up a copy uh if you
happen to have 20 bucks lying around uh
but neil thanks a lot for coming on the
channel again i really enjoyed talking
with you uh and i really love this book
so thanks so much matt i really
appreciate it and thanks for your review
it was really generous
anything i can't do so solidarity left
is best and we hope to talk to you again
in the future yeah i'd love to thank you
[Music]
cool